[Musique]
sans doute y at-il plus de jeunes à
paris qu autrefois ils forment un monde
monde particulier qui vit en marge du
monde que nous connaissons composé comme
chacun sait de croulants et d'amorties
mon particulier qui a son style et ses
modes tirer et bas noirs sont de règle
pour une fille et talons hauts et qui
danse aujourd'hui en ballerines pas de
gants vestiges d'antique tradition
beaucoup de daim et de cuir en veste et
en blouson
[Musique]
l'egypte exige beaucoup de métrage en
ampleur mais peu en hauteur mériteront
peu et à des promenades sentimentale
remplacé par les rendez-vous aux
terrasses des cafés en bois peut
d'ailleurs mais on s'agite beaucoup une
règle impérieuse gouverne la chevelure
le désordre et le fin du fin pour l'un
comme pour l'autre
pas de chapeau bien sûr mais le foulard
des belles négligence le poste à
transistor est à l'honneur car le goût
de la musique ravage les foules
de là la fortune des jo de boxe qui
débite en tranches dur condren la
volonté mais on écoute aussi d'autres
musique bien choisie pire alvin pas
disait on fume beaucoup dans ce monde
plein d'appétit des cigarettes et
française de préférence mais on mange
vite et peu
sandwichs et l'effroi font facilement un
menu
[Musique]
le cinéma est une nécessité vitale et
brigitte bardot est son prophète et l'on
danse book pas la balle c'est bien sûr
calypso ou cha cha cha
le téléphone est un besoin comme la
nourriture et la pensée il faut compter
10 temps 1h de téléphone par jour
lecture on lit encore marcel proust mais
on abandonne le charmant prévert vos
intérêts en tout cas pour les ouvrages
de vulgarisation scientifique ou
technique
les voitures pas n'importe laquelle bien
entendu agite beaucoup les esprits elles
sont rares dans ce monde mais on use
quand même de l'essence détail important
dans ce monde on va par couple et on se
marie jeune centre semblait y attacher
d'importance affaire de style aussi
probablement
[Musique]